healthy walking speed walking is what
you need to do in the DC mall look at
these guys right here I need everyone's
papers how did you get here into this
country no more dreamers
no more dreamers Mike I'm so tired this
is so exhausting we've walked probably
80 steps why should I get the Cinnabon
Mike at the end you have to do a full
workout to get your treat whoa who's
that big red fat guy well that's a
little ease getting all the attention
his kids love said I'm the only big fat
red guy that gets attention around here
whoa take him out take the shot ball
take the shot Walt come on Mike all
right so I'm just gonna take a quick
little break everyone
you leave that man I'm the one
everyone's supposed to like and you're
not gonna take that away from her should
we go shut up right I'm gonna get naked
I think it probably would be best if we
just send him to Guantanamo yeah
Jacob just give him what he wants take
him take it off nice and slow so I can
see it all you know that doesn't that's
not part of it though the sea nice or
mean by it is for me you guys the real
Santa's here
the real Santa right okay little one
come on up whoa whoa whoa where's the
seat sorry sir
just for sanitary purposes go ahead now
what your mother wanna get hi honey how
are you give a father is he still
married to your mother yeah great
forget it what do you think of mitch
mcconnell's jerk right exactly nobody
knows because he's a total nobody you
know what Mitch McConnell wants for
Christmas a chin right am i right what
do you think of Donald travel might shut
up I'm not saying a word
II like Donnell so he always live in you
only that your fire
that's right it does say you're fired
it's always tells whoa what a what am I
on trial yet sir
this whole thing is dumb and the
presents aren't even real okay these
kids believe in some mythological
character doesn't even exist I think
they can right let's face it
have you done whoa Paul come on there we
go
whoa I I guess I can always step in and
take over okay
damn kids
I mean world kids know about respect to
the President on stage and I'm Santa
Claus respect there we go
do you remember the reason for the
season
the birth of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ
let me quote you from the book of Isaiah
I'll use them
lambda by George I think I've got it
enough what I'm doing is stupid Santa
thing anymore we're doing an
old-fashioned rally understand make it
really perfect children children gather
around here wonderful very good ladies
and gentlemen the Santa Clause of the
United States of America there are
millions of children who couldn't even
get into this rally it's so unbelievable
and let me tell you something kids we
don't need homework anymore anybody
we're gonna get rid of the teachers it's
time to drain the swamp
[Music]
girl
I could promise that all of your mothers
will get you literally everything on
your Christmas list or they're going to
jail
[Applause]
get them up get out of here
it turns out mall Santas and I are a lot
alike we both promised gifts we never
actually plan to deliver but for some
reason people keep believing in us
[Applause]